[موسيقى]
لذيذ ومفيد حين تاكلني ستطلب المزيد
وستعشق مني لذيذ ومفيد حين تاكلني ستطلب
المزيد وستعشق ني عنب عنب انا العنب عنب
عنب انا انا العنب عنب عنب انا العنب عنب
عنب انا انا العنب كثيره الواني شكلي بهي
ومنعش عصيري حلو شهي كثيره الوان شكلي بهي
ومنعش عصيري حلو شهي هلم يا شطار غنوا معي
عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب لذيذ
ومفيد حين تاكلني ستطلب المزيد وستعشق ني
لذيذ ومفيد حين تاكلني ستطلب المزيد
وستعشق ني قبل الاكل اغسلني وكلني نقي انا
بالفيتامين جد غني قبل الاكل اغسلني وكلني
نقي انا بالفيتامين جد غني كي اعطيك
الطاقه وجسما قوي عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب
انا العنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب انا
انا العنب لشعبيته عند الجميع يعشقون
الطعم الحلو البديع
لشعبي عند الجميع يعشقون الطعم الحلو
البديع بين الفواكه نوعي رفيع عنب عنب عنب
عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب لذيذ ومفيد حين
تاكلني ستطلب المزيد وستعشق ني لذيذ ومفيد
حين تاكلني ستطلب المزيد وستعشق ني عنب
عنب عنب عنب عنب عنب انا انا العنب عنب
عنب انا العنب عنب عنب انا انا العنب
وا